studying those championship rings sha
there's a lot to cover in that uh yeah
shout out to Jason of Beverly Hill Jason
of B Hill shout out to good job man
every year they do a great job right
that's that's just a cool moment
especially for a franchise that had been
waiting so long and they finally get
that first one and normally
look I haven't seen Joker smiling that
much yeah that's true for a long time he
normally Just Smiles when Shaq tries to
speak Iran to him but but this was what
he's always been talking about it's it's
all about winning it's all about
claiming a championship and he got it
done he he he and his teammates he
reminds me very much of the demeanor of
aakeem Elijah on like hakee when we won
the championship wasn't jumping on the
stanions but when we got the ring he was
super excited that night uh you know it
was the first championship for the for
Houston in any sport when we wanted and
so this here I understand what that
moment feels but the same demeanor as an
Elijah one that strictly business but
it's good to see him smile